how do we know that the sun isn't
causing global warming if the sun
started putting out more light then more
energy would enter the Earth system with
the same amount leaving it and so the
planet would warm up however the
atmosphere doesn't absorb sunlight it
passes right through instead greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere absorb the
thermal radiation coming from the
Earth's surface below so if the sun were
to kick out more energy the planet would
heat up but the atmosphere wouldn't at
least to begin with over time the
atmosphere would start heating from the
bottom up like this the warming of the
atmosphere that we actually observe
however looks like this lower down the
atmosphere is warming up but higher up
it's cooling down let's imagine that you
added lots more greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere they would absorb extra heat
from the planet below and so warm up the
atmosphere close to the surface but the
thermal radiation they absorbed now
doesn't reach the upper atmosphere it
cools down the fact that we observe this
rather than this tells us that the sun
isn't responsible for recent warming
extra greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
are